[Musik]
es ist immer wieder erschreckend
teilweise was für bilder man geht aus
dieser zeit für mich eigentlich
unvorstellbar weil ich heute wie ich
jetzt hier stehe sehr sehr gerne in
freiheit leben weil ich mir halt vor
einigen nicht vorstellen kann dass da
niemand war der irgendwie einhalt
geboten hat und gesagt hat
das geht eigentlich zu weit dass es
macht keinen sinn
[Musik]
ich glaube dadurch dass es
familiengeschichte ist es ist schon
wichtig seine ost identität zu umarmen
weil sie gehört einfach dazu aber ich
würde sie natürlich jetzt nicht krass
zelebrieren aus gefühle also ich würde
jetzt nicht so betiteln
natürlich ist man im osten aufgewachsen
dann wächst dann so rein in diese also
dass auch gesagt wird ja ja die wessis
und da drüben das nimmt man halt einfach
mit auf und das hat sich aber im laufe
meines lebens auch immer mehr
relativiert ja also das beruht glaube
ich eher so auf die auf den älteren
generation und bei uns ist das
eigentlich nicht mehr so das thema
diese glückstränen die bei allen liefen
und was sich wildfremde menschen um den
hals gefallen sind jetzt das gefühl von
freiheit einfach überschwappte bei den
bildern also jedes mal nicht eine sehr
emotionale geschichte für mich einfach
dieses wir finden wieder zueinander wir
sind wieder eins wir sind nicht mehr
geteilt weil die einfach wie konnte ich
das ja gar nicht mehr vorstellen dass so
etwas überhaupt noch passiert und das
war oder ist für mich dann auch wenn ich
sowas sehe natürlich der wahnsinn
gerade jetzt hier auch in diesem
wohnzimmer erinnert nicht oder erinnere
mich die möbel tatsächlich an das eigene
wohnzimmer was meine eltern noch hatten
es ist so dass wir zu hause noch viele
gegenstände auch aus alten zeiten bei
uns fahren ich bin immer gerne ostalgie
wir benutzen sachen wie ein radio zum
beispiel aus ddr-zeiten oder meine
tochter die spielsachen
[Musik]
ich feiere meinen geburtstag bei den
dreißigsten geburtstag und werde meine
freunde einladen tag jeder andere nur
dieses jahr ich mal eine komplette
familie zu einem kabarett eingeladen und
werden gemeinsam verbringen ich nehme
ihn eigentlich gar nicht so besonders
war
von daher ist es einfach nur ein schöner
erfolg